I'm expecting a call from Ginger Rogers
she's unhappy with her representation so
who knows till it's rose Rose her sister
my son he's coming to Hollywood the man
eats with Fred Astaire and Gary Cooper
I'm impressed
hello come in sit Christ man it's all
about ego this whole town runs on ego
yeah I'm Bobby Bonnie come in here can
you Bonnie this is my nephew Bobby how's
the true time Academy Award winner Wow
congratulations thank you you've never
heard of me I'm a writer welcome to
Hollywood
hey [ __ ] bored already I'm kind of
half bored have fascinated my brother
Ben owns a nightclub he's asked me to
help him run it by me you know now we
have to see if the owners going to sell
we're trying to persuade yes politely
people listen are there more beautiful
girls in Hollywood or New York why is
that how you'll decide where you live
you're very beautiful I'm seeing someone
oh I'm a quiet love kills more people in
any year than tuberculosis isn't even
gonna try me listen I'm so lonely I
would have been happy just to talk but
now I'm even too tired for that you like
jazz music at 2:00 in the morning at any
time in the morning
love is not rational you fall in love
you lose control whoa it's a good or bad
no answer is also an entire Socrates
said the unexamined life is not worth
living but the examined one is no
bargaining um yes
life is a comedy written by a sadistic
comedy writer called Leslie had a
disease wherever you are stay there you
sure I will have you arrested
we can't go to mommy's funeral let's do
what we're told we want to see mom